the next step and kind of the
characteristic step or proof by
mathematic conduction is we're going to
assume that there is some value out
there
that will work for this statement right
and we already know there is one but now
i'm going to prove it for an arbitrary
one right or assume it for an arbitrary
one so i'm going to assume that the
statement is true
for
some arbitrary value and i'm going to
call it k
so i'm going to say k has to fit all of
the same criteria that n does which is
namely that it's a positive integer um
so i'm going to say or did i say
positive integer yeah i did so there we
go so i'm going to go
here's the
subset
there we go okay so k obeys all the same
rules that n does and now i just need to
state the statement with k instead of
ends so i'm going to have a to the k
i e
a to the k plus 1 over
and the k is going to be greater than or
equal to
a to the k minus 1 plus its reciprocal
okay so i've just made this assumption i
don't know what i can do with it yet but
now i need to think about well what's
the thing i'm
going to try and prove off the basis of
this so i'm going to look at the next
step along which is the k plus 1 steps
so now i am required to prove
that
it's true
for the next step along given that it's
true for the previous step i e alright
let's do our substitution i'm going to
get a to the k plus 1 plus 1 over
a to the k plus 1 and then when i put in
k plus 1 on the right hand side because
you've got that minus 1 and they just
kind of balance out you get a to the k
plus 1 over a to the k
on the right hand side okay so i don't
know that this is true this is what i'm
setting out to prove okay
now there's a bunch of different ways to
do this but um you know you could for
example start with the um the left-hand
side of this manipulate it until you see
you know say this left-hand side make a
substitution that's a fairly
straightforward way to do it another way
is you could you know gather everything
onto one side you know subtract all of
this on the left hand side and then you
prove that it's greater than or equal to
zero that would also work but the
particular method that i'm going to use
today is i'm just going to start from
the assumption right and then i'm going
to
mold and shape the assumption until it
looks as close as possible to the k plus
one case that i'm trying to prove okay
so i'm going to begin by saying
uh let's write this
and i'm assuming this to be true so i'm
going to say oh i should say that this
is my proof by the way so let's just
grab that over there
here comes the proof
so i'm just going to begin with this
statement that came from the assumption
so i'll say by assumption
so this frees me from having to try and
manipulate the
you know one of these terms to try and
make it look like the assumption i've
just used it already and used it as my
math foundation okay
now what i want to do is i want to try
and get this toward something that looks
like this right that's where i'm headed
and to me the most straightforward thing
to do is to say well i've got an a to
the k and i want it to look a bit like
the a to k plus one so you know so
either you make this thing look like
that or vice versa so i'm doing the vice
versa right
what i'm going to do is to get from
this a to the k and make it look like an
a to the k plus one it's fairly
straightforward to do i just multiply
everything through by a right
that will give me with my index laws a
to the k plus one in the first instance
and then just have a careful look at
what happens to all our terms here right
i do this just to make the working you
know i think easier to follow if i
multiply by a then it appears on the
numerator there but then you've got this
a k that's still on that denominator
from the original line now these two are
going to play ball i'm going to get some
negative indices there but i'm just not
going to do it yet because it's pretty
easy to get confused mixing them up and
you'll see why in a second i'm going to
adjust it okay
greater than or n equal 2 and i'm
multiplying everything on the right hand
side also by a so this is just going to
be a to the k because i just add 1 to
that index and then same deal over here
i'm going to write that a on the
numerator and we're just going to have a
k a to the k minus 1 on the denominator
okay now what i want to do is to make
this easier to work with i'm going to
get these fractions all of the a's that
in the fractions i'm going to combine
them together so it's sort of like
collecting like terms but in index form
right so to do that and make it very
obvious i'm going to divide both the top
and bottom of our fractions by a right
so the fractions remain equivalent but
it's going to get rid of the a's that we
see on the denominator or the numerator
i should say the one on the top are
going to get rid of and what's going to
happen is you're going to get ones on
the bottom
now on the left hand side what that
means is you have that one on the
numerator but because you're dividing
that means subtraction of indices right
so i'm going to get a to the k minus one
just pause there the reason why i'm sort
of drawing this out into two lines some
people might say like can't you just do
this straight away when i was marking
student responses to this question this
was a common thing that got that
students got confused by right they were
dividing through by a so they thought
they were multiplying through by a so
they saw that a to the k and thought oh
well i know what happens when you
multiply through by the same base you
add to the index not noticing that this
was on the denominator so really it's
division so therefore you're actually
sort of dividing by this division which
means it's multiplication you can see
you're getting caught up in essentially
a double negative situation so
so drawing this out into two or two and
a half lines is my way of knowing i get
these indices correct again very common
error to make
i'm going to do the same thing on the
right hand side so you can see here i'm
going to get a 1 on the numerator and
then this a to the k minus 1 you divide
it by a that gives you k minus 2.
all right now
at this point what i want to do is again
move toward what i've got here in my k
plus one case right so i've already got
this a to the k plus one so i can sort
of tick that off but i'm missing a one
over a to the k plus one and i've got
this term instead okay so i'm going to
do two things at once which is a bit
dicey but you'll see why in a second i
think you'll be able to follow it
firstly um this uh
a to the k minus one term let's just
highlight that in purple
um i don't want it on the left hand side
it doesn't belong there right so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to subtract
it from both sides so that leaves me
with
everything here is unchanged
but then i'm going to subtract this
1 over a to the k minus 1 term
and i'm getting it from over here
okay so so far so good at the same time
you might notice that what i actually
want is um i want this term also to
appear right so let's just highlight
that in in blue right there so i want
that to appear on the left hand side and
it's not there so therefore i'm going to
add it in i'm going to say plus 1 over a
to the k plus 1 and of course if you add
it to the left you had better be adding
it to the
right like so right so i hope you're
satisfied with that you can see i've
subtracted this from both sides landing
it over here and then i've added this
simultaneously to the left and right
hand side okay
now what's great about this is a bunch
of things let's just carefully have a
look at
i'm just going to highlight this like so
this is where i want to head this is my
destination right and then you can see
my final line of working currently my
current line of working i should say
let's just step through it one step at a
time so we can have a you know we've
done a bunch of algebraic manipulation i
want to know i'm heading in the right
direction okay
as i step through it one at a time
you'll see i've checked off a lot of
things right firstly this a to the k
plus one term i've got that right so i'm
going to say that looks good
it doesn't need to go anywhere
i've also got this 1 over a to the k
plus 1 term it's right here so check the
whole left hand side is exactly the way
that i want it so that's looking good
inequality is facing the correct
direction that's always a good sign and
then lastly in terms of what i've got
already you've got this a to the k term
on the right hand side which is right
there she'll like check also good
all that leaves me with is this okay now
that looks like a huge mess and what i
want it to look like is
is this right i wanted to i don't know
why that did that i'm going to select
there we go
i want this 1 over a to the k i want to
work on this term here and show that it
is greater than or equal to this that is
the destination it's very messy but i
should be able to get there and um
there's still a bit of a curveball to go
but you can see the path that i'm headed
toward everything else looks good i'm
not even going to write the left hand
side anymore because it's perfect
i'm just going to work on these terms on
the right hand side
the a to the k is there and then i'll
look at this
and i'm like hmm what do i do with it
okay now you've got all of these
denominators that you can see are very
closely related they have all got the
same base a
and then they've also got something that
i want namely this this k index right
you can see it right here here and here
but then you've got this other stuff
that's floating around okay so in order
to try and get at the bit that i want
i'm going to factorize out 1 over a to
the k and the reason i can do that is
because it's here and here and here it
appears all three times so if i just
factorize that out 1 over a to the k
what does that leave me with in the
brackets just be super careful we've
already noticed the index laws have been
flying around
thick and fast so i'm going to do as few
changes as possible here okay
on the denominator of the first fraction
i've taken out that a to the k what gets
left behind is a to the negative 2. i
hope you can see that right there just
comes along for the right okay
when i go along to the next term same
deal except it's a to the negative 1 and
then lastly i've got a 1 over a to the 1
which is just a okay
does that look okay to you right what
have i done i've taken all the common
factors out of a to the k and that's
left me with the rest of this stuff the
rest of the a's on the denominator that
you can see all right
now hold up for a second right look at
this this is looking very promising okay
i've got the a to the k that i saw
before it's here
i've got the one on a to the k right
there and then i've just got this stuff
over here okay now if this object over
here is greater than or equal to one
then it's going to be multiplying by one
or negative k so you can see you're
going to get this result here right if
it's one or if it's one and a half or
two then this result will be greater
than or equal to this result and that's
what i'm after okay so therefore now i'm
kind of like collapsing down i'm
focusing in you can see i don't need to
worry about the left hand side anymore
don't need to worry about this out of
the k anymore i don't even need to worry
about this one or a to the k i'm just
focusing on this i want to want to prove
that it's greater than or equal to one
because then when i multiply by one or
negative k then i get one out of the k
or something bigger which is what i'm
after okay
so let's try and rework this right i can
go greater than
all of this stuff here i'm just going to
leave it
as is
i've got i was very cautious with these
indices right because you've got
negative indices flying around and a lot
of factorization now i'm ready to sort
of put it into a more helpful form i've
got a negative index but it's on the
denominator so therefore one on a to the
negative two is just a squared
same deal with one on a to the negative
one it's just minus a
and i'm going to leave that one over a
right there okay
take a breath now here is the last
little curveball okay how do i prove
that this object here let's just go back
to this i want to prove that this is
greater than
what might i'll just use the symbol i
don't know why i'm making it so hard for
myself i want to prove that it's greater
than or equal to one okay now you've got
a couple of options here right and one
of the options that is a really good
candidate is one that you already used
today which is just going back to our
testing our base case
we got this
one sorry a plus one over a and i needed
to prove that it was greater than or
equal to two and we used calculus to do
it okay now you can pull that exact same
trip trick on this function here right
this is a real function right and i can
look at this and think okay well can i
find some stationary points can i prove
that they're minima and off you go okay
now it's totally doable you can okay
however
and let me just prove that you can okay
let's just have a think about what this
function is going to look like i'm just
going to grab it over here
if i graph this as i'm just going to do
it in x because same deal doesn't matter
what the variable is called x squared
minus x
plus 1 over
x okay now for starters what i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to i should
have just adjusted my domain here
because i don't need to worry about the
part that's uh to the left
over there that's negative because we
know that a has to be greater than 0. so
it's just really that part over there so
when you have a look here right
you can see
all right there we
uh am i gonna get my uh scale right i
think you can read it right can you see
there ah there we go no no that'll find
that'll be fine right
sorry talking to myself you can see this
function here right it does indeed have
a minimum just like we did when we were
testing our base case and the minimum is
right there at one we wanted to be
proving that this was greater than or
equal to one what a relief that it
actually is so i can go ahead and i can
pull calculus on this however the reason
i'm not going to do it in this case is
because when you go and have a look at
this function to prove that this is
going to have a minimum turning point
and find the derivative or that kind of
thing
because of the particular function that
you've got here when you differentiate
or indeed find your second derivative
you're going to be dealing with a cubic
and it's pretty gross it's not nice to
deal with um cubic functions we used to
spend a lot more time on polynomials and
how to factorize them and solve them and
all that kind of thing
but cubics are gross in fact fun fact
cubic functions are so gross that back
in the i want to say 1500s italian
mathematicians had so much trouble with
trying to solve cubic polynomials they
literally had to invent complex numbers
to do it so there's a fun little story
there that you can explore if you like
but what i want to suggest is there's
actually a different tool that we can
use
and i think it's interesting because
we've already used calculus today
is a different tool that we can use to
prove that this thing is greater than or
equal to one